okay let's talk about what we'll cover
in the class
so
this course goes through a variety of
deep reinforcement learning methods
construed very broadly but we'll start
with some Basics we'll start by talking
about how we can take a journey from
supervised learning uh methods to
decision making methods provide some
definitions and generally come to
understand the reinforcementing problem
then we'll have a unit on model 3
reinforcement learning algorithms where
we'll cover Q learning policy gradient
and actual critic methods and you'll
have some homeworks where you'll
Implement each of these then we'll have
another unit on model based algorithms
we'll talk about planning optimal
control sequence models images and
things like that and then we'll have a
variety of more advanced topics we're
going to cover exploration algorithms
we're going to cover algories for
offline reinforcement learning which are
methods that can use both data and
reinforcement learning methods
we'll talk about inverse reinforcement
learning which deals with inferring
objective functions from behavior and
have some discussion there about the
relationship between reinforcement
learning methods and things like
probabilistic inference and then we'll
have a few Advanced topics like metal
learning and transfer learning maybe
hierarchical RL and a set of research
talks and invited lectures so that's the
overall overview of the class you're
going to have five assignments uh there
will be an assignment of limitation
learning policy gradients Q learning and
after credit algorithms model based RL
and the last one will be on offline RL
and there will be a final project the
final project is a research level
product project of your choice you can
form a group of up to two to three
students and you're more than welcome to
start on this project early
the students every year have some
questions about our expectations for the
scope of this project roughly speaking
you should think about it as roughly the
level of a paper that you might submit
for example to a workshop if you're not
sure about the scope of your project
definitely come into office hours to
talk to the Tas or to myself
we will have multiple rounds of feedback
for you for your project so we'll have a
project proposal deadline and our
project Milestone report these are
really meant for you we strongly
encourage you to write up your plan to
describe potential concerns you know
about your plan and so on and we'll give
you feedback on those so the proposal
and the Milestone are not greater very
strictly they really meant much more as
a way for you to get feedback on your
project Plan before the final report at
the end of the semester
you'll be great at 50 on the homeworks
40 on the project and ten percent on
quizzes after every lecture
and
you'll have a total of five or eight
days for your homeworks don't exceed
those five late days those five late
days total uh if you exceed them then we
uh you know unfortunately cannot give
you credit for that homework
uh you also have a little bit of
homework for today
uh make sure that you're signed up for
Ed uh UC Berkeley cs285
all of you who have been signed up for
the enrolled in the course officially
would have receive an invitation for
this
we strongly encourage you to start
forming project groups unless you want
to work alone which is fine and take the
lecture one quits so the lecture one
quizzes post Seven Grade scope the
lecture one quizzes uh very much a
practice quiz it's not a there's not a
real quiz there uh and it's really to be
familiar with a great scope interface
however what I want to focus on mainly
in today's lecture is discussing why we
should study reinforced learning what it
is and a little bit of context for why I
myself like to teach this class but
let's start with some Basics what is
reinforcement learning
well reinforcement learning is really
two things it's a mathematical formalism
for learning based decision making and
it's also an approach for learning
decision making and control from
experience
and it's important to keep in mind these
are somewhat separate because we could
imagine taking the formalism and then
applying all sorts of different methods
to it so it's important not to confuse
reinforcement learning the problem from
reinforced learning the solution
okay how does this differ from other
machine learning topics well the kind of
machine learning that most of you are
probably familiar with is supervised
learning supervised learning is fairly
straightforward to Define you have a
data set of inputs and outputs we refer
them typically as X and Y and you want
to learn to predict y from X so you want
to learn some kind of function f of x
which outputs values y that are close to
the Y labels in the data set so for
example F might be represented by a deep
neural network that you would train via
classificational regression to match the
labels y
and
while the basic formulation of
supervised machine learning is very
straightforward
supervised machine learning methods make
a number of assumptions that we often
don't even think about because they're
so natural but that are important to
bring up if we're going to discuss how
this difference from reinforcement
learning
supervised learning typically assumes
what is called independent and
identically distributed data this is
such an obvious assumption in some ways
especially for someone who studied
machine learning that we often don't
make it explicit but what it means is
that all of these X Y pairs in your data
set
are independent of one another in the
sense that the label for One X doesn't
influence the label for another X
and they're distributed identically in
the sense that the true function that
produced the label y from X is the same
for all the samples it's almost an
obvious statement but it's something
that is important to keep in mind
supervised learning also assumes that
our data set is labeled in the sense
that every X we've seen in D also has an
accompanying Y and that Y is the true
label for the X
this is very natural if you're doing
things like image classification with
labels obtained from humans but remember
how we discussed in the grasming example
this can actually be pretty unnatural if
you want a robot to learn how to grasp
objects it's actually a very strong
assumption to assume that you're given a
set of images with ground truth optimal
grasp locations
reinforcement learning does not assume
that the data is independent identically
distributed in the sense that previous
outputs influence future inputs things
are Arrangement temporal sequence and
the past influences the future
typically the ground truth answer is not
known it's only known how good a
particular outcome was whether it was a
failure or a success or more generally
what its reward value was
so in reinforcement learning
you might collect data but you can't
simply copy that data that doesn't
actually lead to success the data might
tell you which things were successful
and which things fail although even
those labels are difficult to interpret
properly because if you have a sequence
of events that led to a failure you
don't know which event which particular
choice in that sequence was the one that
precipitated the failure this is not
unlike
human decision making perhaps you've got
a really bad grade at the end of a
course well it wasn't the fact that you
looked looked up your grade on Cal
Central that caused you to get the bad
grade it was something you did earlier
in the class perhaps the fact that you
did poorly on an exam
at the time perhaps you didn't realize
that this would lead you to fail the
course so this is very much an issue
that we have in reinforcement learning
referred to as credit assignment where
the decision that actually results in a
bad outcome or a good outcome might not
itself be labeled with a higher low
reward the reward might only happen
later
so we need to take this data which is
not labeled with crunch with optimal
outputs and might involve these delayed
rewards run reinforcement learning on it
and hopefully get a behavior that is
better than the behavior we saw before
so that's really the challenge in
reinforcement
so let's try to make this a little bit
more precise in supervised learning you
have an input X and you have an output Y
and you have a data set that consists of
X Y pairs the goal is to learn a
function
that takes an X and approximates Y and
typically this function has some
parameters which we refer to as Theta
these might be for example the weights
in a neural network
in reinforcement learning we have a kind
of a cyclical online learning procedure
where an agent interacts with the world
the agent chooses actions a t at every
point in time and the world responds
with the resulting State s t plus 1 and
reward signal and the reward signal
simply indicates how good that state is
but it doesn't necessarily tell you if
the action that you just took was a good
or bad action perhaps you got lucky and
landed in a good state or perhaps you
did something really good earlier that
caused you to get into a good State now
the input to our agent is going to be
the state St at each time step so this
kind of the analog of X the output is 80
at each time step
the data which is collected by the agent
itself classically consists of sequences
of States actions and rewards rewards
are numbers scalar values
and whereas in supervised learning the
data is given to you you don't have to
worry about
who gave you the data it's just provided
to you as a set of XY tuples in
reinforcement learning you have to pick
your own actions and collect your own
data so not only do you have to worry
about the fact that the actions in your
data set might not be the optimal
actions you have to also actually decide
how that data will be collected
and your goal is to learn a policy Pi
Theta which Maps States s to actions a
and just like f Pi has parameters Theta
so those might again be the weights in a
neural network
and a good policy is one that maximizes
the cumulative total reward so not just
the rewarding the point in time but the
total reward the agent receives
so that involves strategic reasoning
maybe you might do something that might
seem unrewarding now to attain higher
rewards later
so
let's talk about some examples of how
problems could be cast in the
terminology of reinforcement learning
let's say that you'd like to train a dog
to perform some trick right so in this
case the actions might be the muscle
contractions of the dog's muscles the
observations might be what the dog
perceives through its sense of sight and
smell the reward might be the treat that
it gets and the dog will then learn to
do whatever maximize that reward which
might be the trick that you want to
perform because you're rewarded with
food when the dog performs the tree the
trick successfully
okay here's another example maybe you
have a robot its actions might be the
motor current or pork some kind of
actuation command sent to its Motors its
observations might be the readings from
its sensors like camera amateurs and its
reward might be some measure of test
success maybe this robot needs to run as
fast as possible to reach your
destination so its reward function might
be the running speed or it might be the
whether it reached the destination or
not just maybe it receives a plus one
when it reaches the destination
successfully and a minus one otherwise
here's another problem let's say you
want to manage inventory route goods
between different warehouses in order to
maintain stock levels
perhaps the actions are which inventory
to purchase
the observations are the current
inventory levels and the reward might be
the profit you make perhaps you have to
pay if you want to store inventory for a
long time so your profits will be lower
so you can see that this formulation is
very general many different problems can
be cast into the framework of
reinforcement
we'll of course make all this a lot more
precise later so this is a very high
level introduction don't worry yet if
the particular details aren't very clear
will make us a lot more precise in later
lectures
but for now let me just give you some
examples of the kinds of things that
reinforce some learning methods could do
one of the things that reinforcement
learning is very good at is learning
policies for physically complex tasks
tasks where it might be very difficult
for a person to describe precisely how
the tasks should be performed but much
easier to find the reward like in this
case the rewards that the nails should
be hammered in and the reinforced
learning algorithm figures out how to
control this robotic hand to move the
hammer to hammer in the nail
here's another complex physical task
here this quadrupedal robot needs to be
able to jump over different obstacles
now coding up manually a skill for
jumping like this is very tough but
reinforcement one can learn the
actuations that will allow the robot to
jump in different locations to various
distances and so on
it can even perform more physically
complex tasks so here this in the next
clip the quadrupedal robot uh this is a
baseline method so don't worry about
this share this quadrupedal robot needs
to figure out how to stand on its hind
legs and balance and that's also very
difficult to do manually but with an
appropriate reinforced morning method
that's actually possible
impact reinforcement learning has been
applied very very widely to robotic
problems here's a an even more recent
work and this is from eth Zurich showing
a robot using reinforcement with a
combination of simulated optimization to
learn various agile skills and you can
see that it might clamor onto obstacles
and things like that
now the other thing that reinforced
learning is great at is coming up with
unexpected Solutions I alluded to this
before with the alphago example here's
another example which you'll actually
Implement in your homeworks where a key
learning algorithms learn to play Atari
and discover the strategy that if you
bounce the ball up over the bricks then
it will bounce around you'll get lots of
points
reinforcement can also be applied at
larger scale in the real world this is a
project that was done at a company
called Everyday Robots versus alphabet
company where the robots learn to sort
trash so the idea is that if people put
trash into recyclables that should
actually go into the compost then the
robot can come and sort it the robots
here learn in the real world
in both in these classroom environments
where they can practice and in like
actual Office Buildings and these
vision-based skills that are kind of
similar in spirit to the ones that I
mentioned in the beginning uh
can then pick up and move objects in
real world Office Buildings so that's
pretty neat that you can actually
practice these things you can practice
them on the job you can practice them in
the real world
and it's of course not just for games
and robots
um
I I really like this next example this
is work that was done by Kathy Wu who's
now a professor at MIT and was
previously a PhD student here at UC
Berkeley and what Kathy was working on
his reinforcement learning algorithms
for controlling traffic
um this is a kind of a toy example where
these cars drive in a circle and what
tends to happen even in a simple
circular environment like this if you
have a very uh reasonable a very
accurate model of what human drivers
behave you'll actually get traffic jams
forming spontaneously so cars will kind
of bunch up and when they Bunch up like
this they'll actually have spontaneously
form traffic jams even though they drive
in a circle
so what Kathy then did is she optimized
the reinforced learning policy which
will be shown next for the car shown in
red
to not optimize its its own speed but to
optimize the speed of the entire circle
and you can see that what this car in
red is going to do is going to actually
slow down and wait for everybody to
resolve the traffic jam and by going a
little bit slower it'll actually avoid
the formation of traffic jams in the
entire circle
Kathy also experimented with this in
other settings this is a a figure eight
kind of intersection and as you might
expect cars will Bunch up at the center
section and cause delays so if there's
an autonomous car that is trying to
optimize the uh driving speed of all the
cars the autonomous car will actually
slow down a little bit
and regulate the traffic so that
everyone passes through the intersection
at exactly the perfect time now this
example maybe is a little bit synthetic
but there's a considerable follow-up
work to this showing that in fact
autonomous regulation of traffic with
reinforced money can be quite a powerful
tool
reinforcement has also been used very
widely with language models uh many of
you are probably familiar with the
advances in recent language models of
things like chat GPT and many other
systems like anthropics Claude or
Google's Bard which use large amounts of
data to train models that will fulfill
user requests
and this is an example on the right
where someone asks child should be T to
explain how RL with human feedback works
for language models and it produces some
kind of explanation
now
by themselves large language models
train on lots of internet data
can solve their sophisticated problems
but it's quite difficult to persuade
them to do this because these models are
basically trying to complete text based
on what they learned from internet data
so you have to prompt them in a way that
kind of indexes into the right context
reinforcement learning can be used to
make this a lot easier by essentially
training these models based on human
scores so instead of just asking them to
provide the kind of completions that are
most likely from internet data they can
actually be trained to respond to
queries in ways that human readers find
to be desirable and reinforced learning
is actually a very important part of
this
reinforcement learning has also been
used with image generation here's an
example with a stable diffusion 1.4 if
you ask it to generate a picture of a
dolphin riding a bike it actually
generates a picture that is not very
good for this what you can do is you can
take this image and you can give it to a
captioning model in this case lava to
produce a description of the image and
then use RL where the reward function is
given by the similarity between the
description from lava and the original
prompt so when lava looks at this
picture it might say oh this is a
picture of a dolphin above the water
which is not very similar to Dolphin
riding a bike so that so it receives a
bad reward for that
if we then optimize the image generation
model with RL to maximize this reward
it'll gradually make the image more
appropriate to The Prompt so now there's
both a dolphin and a bicycle although
the dolphin is not writing the bicycle
just yet with a few more iterations now
there's a dolphin like creature that is
in fact on a bicycle and with some more
iterations the creature begins much more
clearly a dolphin apparently putting
some waves in the background makes it
extra dolphin-like and then eventually
there's a full-fledged picture of a
dolphin riding a bicycle so reinforced
learning can be used to optimize image
generation models
reinforcement one can also be used for
other things this is an example on chip
design where the actions correspond to
placement of Chip parts per layout and
the reward has to do with various chip
design parameters like the cost or the
congestion or latency of the chip
so rainforcement can actually be applied
By plot
so I'll pause here and in the next
section I'll discuss why we should study
deep RL today